What's the time of sunset tomorrow? For sure, we can answer that by simulation.
We already simulated the motion of the moon around the earth
and in the similar way, we can simulate the motion of the earth around the sun
and the rotation of the earth.
Are dolphins more intelligent than elephants?
To answer this question by simulation which we try our model of how intelligence develops
and depends on biology, that is pretty hard to do and may be impossible.
Can neutrinos travel faster than light? That's something that physicists have to measure.
You could imagine the model that contains more fundamental objects than neutrinos
super strings for instance and the neutrinos could be simulated using super strings,
but that's again far from the current state of the art and may be impossible.
Who invented the telephone?
To answer that question, you would have to model all of human history inside the computer
That doesn't sound plausible.